[Music]
[Music]
she is one of hundreds of farmers in
taiwan who grow at the moya a variety of
custard apples
today
[Music]
it's one of the island's most popular
fruit exports every season farmers like
che export around 14 million kilos and
90 percent of that goes to china
but in september of 2021 china banned
all imports of atemoyas they claimed
they had pests
[Music]
overnight shell lost 70 of his orders
but this story is about more than just
fruit pests or trade atemoyas are a
symbol of deep tensions between taiwan
and china that have been simmering
for decades
so how did this innocent tropical fruit
get caught in the middle of all this
[Music]
the complicated relationship between
china and taiwan dates back to the 1940s
back then china was in the middle of a
brutal civil war between the
nationalists and the communists
when the communists won they established
the people's republic of china on the
mainland the nationalists fled to taiwan
and called it the republic of china they
both declared themselves the rightful
ruler of china a claim that only the
mainland really upholds taiwan isn't
officially recognized as an independent
country but it has developed into a
self-governing democracy with a
constitution legislature and president
since the civil war ended taiwan's kmt
party has been in power most of the time
and while they maintained sovereignty
they also grew closer to china but in
2014 many felt they got too close
they passed a trade pact that opened up
taiwanese industries to chinese
investment
and thousands of protesters stormed the
government
they feared the pact would hurt taiwan's
economy and leave it vulnerable to
pressure from china
soon after taiwan's opposition party was
voted into power for only the second
time in the island's history
and this new president continued to push
back against china
um
instead china has intensified its
pressure campaign to unify taiwan with
the mainland
military incursions are on a steep rise
china has sent hundreds of fighter jets
into taiwanese airspace and they've
conducted military drills designed to
intimidate
they've also coerced other countries and
world organizations from formally
recognizing taiwan
a big part of china's pressure campaign
comes down to isolating taiwan from the
rest of the world
but with this tropical fruit china is
doing something different it's
pressuring taiwan from within
[Music]
china is taiwan's largest trading
partner
more than a quarter of all exports go to
the mainland
and that's in part because they offer
incentives like dropping all tariffs on
these taiwanese fruits
[Music]
and this net can easily trap farmers
like she who switched to growing at the
moyes exclusively seven years ago
um
there was so much money to be made
selling to china that many farmers in
the region also switched to atamoya and
production tripled
this brought jobs and a more sustainable
economy
but there was a catch
because of all the incentives china
offers taiwan a huge number of farmers
rely on china to make a living
and this creates a dangerous dependency
because it allows china to disrupt trade
flow with say a fruit ban that hurts
fruit farmers in taiwan which could push
them into blaming the government for
worsening relations with china
[Music]
and while the threat might be aimed at
taiwan's government it's farmers like
che who feel the impact the most since
the ban his income has dropped by more
than 50 percent
the uh
are the latest target but not the only
one china also banned wax apples and in
early 2021 pineapples too just like with
atemoya's china claimed the pineapples
had pests
[Music]
pineapples are the most popular fruit
exported to china
they account for about 60 million us
dollars
so pineapple farmers are stuck in the
same cycle of dependency
but for this ban taiwan tried something
different they launched a campaign and
it went viral
world leaders and diplomats posed with
the taiwanese pineapple
and japan and hong kong replaced china
as taiwan's top pineapple importers
domestically citizens bought an entire
year's worth of pineapple exports in
four days restaurants across the island
added pineapple to everything
and it helped
but dependency on china runs deep
china wasn't just a big market it was an
especially profitable one
[Music]
[Music]
that's because if taiwan doesn't sell
fruit to china their only choice is to
go north to japan and south korea
further south in southeast asia tropical
fruits are much cheaper longer distances
are also complicated for fresh fruits
that require cool temperatures and
special storage conditions at home the
taiwanese government has offered
financial help but most of it is going
to exporters and not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so instead of trying to replace the
deep-rooted market china created some
farmers are starting to replace their
crops
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
because as long as taiwan's farmers are
trapped in the middle of this
geopolitical fight
their livelihoods will always be
at risk
[Music]
you